hello and good morning you're watching
Sky News breakfast now Russian State
television is reporting that President
Putin has visited the Ukrainian city of
mariopol it's believed to be his first
visits to Russian occupied territories
of Ukraine's donbass region since the
war broke out well this footage is said
to be President Putin driving around the
streets of Mario pole the port city was
captured by Russia in the early months
of the war after Fierce fighting
specifically around the as of style
steel plant and the city there it's now
been largely destroyed though Russia has
been rebuilding parts of it to try and
erase its Ukrainian identity
and according to the state's television
you can see Putin here has visited the
city's Philharmonic theater the same
Hall allegedly being used by Russia to
hold prisoners of War during sham trials
that were held in Mario upon
well earlier he's visited Crimea a
peninsula Russia claimed as its own from
Ukraine nine years ago that trip came
just hours and he was made the subject
of an arrest warrant over the Abduction
of children from Ukraine our
International correspondent John Sparks
is this
the Russian President Vladimir Putin is
liable to arrest in 123 countries but no
one will detain him in Crimea the
territory seized from Ukraine in 2014.
and he marked the anniversary of its
annexation with a tour of this Art
Center
this is good he says he looked unruffled
and Unapologetic and that was almost
certainly the point
what is it in total an art school asks
Putin
yes an art school and a children's camp
replies the priest we've agreed that
we'll select children that are very
talented
his visit came one day after the
international criminal court accused him
of abducting children from Ukraine to
Russia
[Music]
but these allegations are dismissed by
his supporters in Crimea who were out
rallying and riding motorcycles in the
city of simpheropol here the president
enjoys the people's blessing Crimean
spring for nine years we are together
States this flag
the court has accused Putin and the
country's children's commissioner of the
forced deportation of children and it's
easily provable both have appeared on
television discussing it I think for
many uh international criminal lawyers a
a refreshing and encouraging sign that
prosecutor Khan is making a decision
here to prosecute first a case that he
knows he can prove with very little
difficulty but as I say more charges are
bound to follow
Russia has been accused of committing
multiple human rights violations in
Ukraine including attacks on civilians
missiles hit a place called evdifka just
after the court announced its indictment
but the court has put everyone on notice
war crimes past and future will be
prosecuted
President Putin will not accept
responsibility and he won't present
himself for trial but he now celebrates
the annexation of Crimea as an
international fugitive from Justice
John Sparks Sky News
let's get a little reaction to the news
that President Putin has visited Mario
poll by speaking to the former special
advisor on Russian and Eurasian Affairs
Mark Voyager is joining us now from
Sofia in Bulgaria Mark Voyager good to
have you with us it's always a pleasure
to have your analysis so I mean what do
you make of the fact that we're seeing
Putin turn up in Crimea and now in Mario
poll in the days after the ICC have
issued that arrest warrant a good
morning Kamali um thank you for having
always a pleasure well we we gotta admit
that Putin uh is really the master of
strategic surprises especially uh when
it comes to the information space
um by his appearance first uh in Crimea
and now in mariopol he is trying to send
two important messages both to the West
as well so his domestic audiences to the
West the message is one of defiance you
know especially uh you know with this
visit coming uh on the wings of the ICC
um uh uh decision ruling in The Hague
pretty much he's showing that he's
Unapologetic uh and he um you know
effectively he wants to show that he's
um above uh those uh those legal
developments uh and also these people
he's showing that he's in control
um ultimately uh you know as you saw
he's visiting different locations there
he wants to show the Russian people that
you know he's taking care of things that
he's personally involved this is part of
this uh information Warfare which is
really the centerpiece of Russian hybrid
Warfare but also of Putin's
personalistic uh grip on power I mean
the stability of his regime is the
center of gravity for Putin and
therefore he he knows how to play this
information game quite well and
information uh uh Warfare requires also
escalation dominance also if the West
does something uh to try to
um put pressure on him he lashes out he
pushes against that with such
um messages which the search visits and
also of course he's saying uh he's
telling the world in Ukraine Crimea is
ours obviously the 18th of March was the
anniversary of the illegal annexation of
Crimea by Russia so many messages Putin
is Unapologetic he's not yielding
obviously and he's still you know
capable of surprising both the domestic
and international audiences with such
young
am I that effort to control the
information space as you say is is when
the President Putin is a master in but I
do wonder about the decision as well to
visit the particular areas that he has
including so the chill children center
in Crimea and then a theater in mariopol
with a sort of symbolism that that will
have well that
well the idea that he's gone to a
children's center in Crimea the
directory is accused of illegally
deporting children from Ukraine to
Russia well that that message won't be
lost on the Russian people will it no of
course yeah absolutely they will spin
the story as uh you know they always do
that put in uh actually loves children
but he takes care of children uh that
what what he and his commissioner for uh
for uh children's uh Affairs did was
actually uh you know benevolent
beneficial for those children et cetera
I mean the Russian propaganda knows how
to spin those stories uh yeah you're
right these are well selected uh um
sites uh for the purposes of Russia's uh
this information campaign and it's
definitely tied to uh this um ICC ruling
this is part of of the kremlin's uh
narrative and and it's it's so we we can
we can say that the information uh
Warfare has begun the information
campaign to actually uh try to exonerate
put in at least in the eye of the
Russian population of those Nations and
audiences that support Russia yeah and
let's just look at a couple of uh hours
24 hours or so uh mark because there is
still a plan in place for president Xi
Jinping to travel to meet Putin I guess
Putin will have to travel back from
marry your Poll for the meeting in
Moscow what difficulties is that going
to place on President XI and the Chinese
State who you know before the War Began
said they were standing back to back
with Russia but now President Putin is
an indicted war criminal we'll be um I
would say a serious reputational blow to
um present C uh obviously meeting with
someone who is now a pariah effectively
a criminal in the eyes of the Civilized
world and of course China still depends
on its commercial relations with the
West uh especially Western Europe where
the court is located but on the other
hand the sea is an ideological uh leader
and I suspect that in this case ideology
the ideological affiliations and the
alignments of of his interests with with
those of of Putin that is distracting
the west and keeping the West uh
um involved in a theater that's away
from Taiwan away from East Asia might
actually play uh better for Cedar for
um I mean I would be surprised if he
cancels the visit obviously there are
many many important things to decide
there the supply of Chinese ammunition
which has been I reported already by uh
by the U.S intelligence uh therefore
um the propaganda will find a way to
spin it both on the Chinese and the in
the Russian side and and uh you know
explain it away
yeah okay Mark I do appreciate your
analysis as well thank you very much
thank you avoid you there
now to some other news this morning and
back here illegal migrants who arrive in
the UK could be flown to Rwanda before
the summer the Home Secretary swella
Bradman is in the African nation and
suggested the first flights could leave
for them in a matter of weeks she
acknowledged however that the timetable
is dependent on legal challenges to the
policy the controversial plan is a key
part of which sunax pledge to stop small
boats carrying migrants crossing the
channel our political correspondent my
Aurora reports
virtual partnership
heard by legal challenges Home Secretary
Suella bravaman this weekend met with
the Rwandan foreign affairs minister to
a green expansion of the deportation
policy whereby not only Asylum Seekers
but also those claiming to be victims of
modern slavery could be removed from the
UK
but with the scheme having deported a
total of zero migrants to the African
nation so far the clock is ticking to
get migrants on planes and into
accommodation ahead of the next general
election
progresses being made rapidly and I'm
really confident on the back of the
progress that I've seen here in Kigali
that we will be able to operationalize
this world leading agreement very very
soon our laws will dramatically reduce
the Avenues for exploitation so that you
won't be able to thwart our power to
remove and not everyone in Rwanda agrees
with the UK government
I want to make this
we are not because we support welcoming
or refugees that are from Congo from
Burundi from wherever because they
choose to come to another but these ones
they never chose to come to Rwanda they
chose to go to the UK so they are not
our responsibility
but with pressure from conservative
backbench MPS to reduce net migration
and the government's immigration Bill
making its way through stages of
parliamentary scrutiny as we speak the
Home Secretary is desperate to be seen
to be on top of her brief
although challenges may be minimal in
Rwanda
back on home soil there Still Remains
Fierce opposition to the concept of
Outsourcing the UK's migration problems
to other nations
[Applause]
but refugees should not be treated
inhumanely and cruelly when they come to
the UK
is not even a political view it's basic
morality if people come on a boat how
extreme must your situation be
the Home Secretary has said it would be
her dream come true to see migrants
flown to Rwanda thanks so much for
coming but you may not be smiling for
long if her Flagship policy fails to see
the light of day Mario Aurora Sky News
and that Flagship policy will no doubt
be a main talking point when Sophie
Ridge on Sunday begins at 8 30 it was
speaking to Oliver Dowden the chancellor
of the duchy of Lancaster and getting
the view from the labor party when Lisa
nandy the shadow leveling up so is on
the program there's a big political week
ahead as Boris Johnson will be giving
evidence to the Privileges committee on
Wednesday about partygate and Sophie and
the team will tell you everything you
need to know that all begins at 8 30.
now Donald Trump has used his social
media sites truth social to claim he's
going to be arrested on Tuesday the
former president is being investigated
over a payment made to the adult film
actor Stormy Daniels to cover up an
alleged Affair our U.S correspondent
James Matthews has the latest
it would be the first time that a former
U.S president has been indicted it
relates to an affair that Donald Trump
allegedly had with an adult film actress
Stormy Daniels 10 years ago just before
the 2016 election there were concerns in
the Trump camp that she would go public
with that story and to that end she was
paid a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars by Donald Trump's lawyer now
that's not a crime the hush money isn't
a crime but what prosecutors are looking
at is how that was put through the books
of the Trump organization they believe
there may have been a crime a
falsification in that and possibly a
breach of campaign Finance laws we have
been expecting an announcement of an
indictment from the prosecutors in
Manhattan but Donald Trump appears to
have beaten them to it on his social
media site and in doing so he has he has
stated protest take our nation back and
these are menacing words that do a vote
book memories of the January the 6th
Insurrection and his opponents have
criticized him for fomenting potential
trouble around this legal process there
are big questions around next week not
just on the logistics New York
authorities preparing for crowds for
potential protests but also there is the
potential spectacle of Donald Trump
being fingerprinted having his mug shot
taken potentially being taken on a
so-called part walk where he is in
handcuffs escorted by the police in
public although that will depend on the
extent to which he cooperates with
authorities but all sorts of questions
that extend beyond the courtroom of
course to do with the political impact
of all of this remember Donald Trump
faces legal Jeopardy on a number of
fronts to do with January the 6th to do
with classified documents found in his
home in Mar-A-Lago and also to do with
alleged attempts to overturn the
election in Georgia in 2020.
James Massey is there reporting from
Washington now back here in emergency
alert services to be launched to warn
people about potentially
life-threatening events like wildfires
and severe flooding the government's
planning to test the system next month
meaning people across the UK can expect
to receive a siren-like message on their
mobile phone our correspondent Alice
portrait is here with more details about
it Alice good to have you with us good
morning to you so just tell us what are
the details of this scheme well your
phone or tablet if there was going to be
one of these emergency alerts it would
have a siren that would go on for about
10 seconds it could vibrate and it would
sort of read out a message and these
would be messages from government bodies
or bodies which are dealing with an
emergency situation in the vicinity of
where you are now these emergency alerts
will only be sent when there's an
immediate risk to people's lives they
include things like it's a bit of
flooding fires extreme weather and
public health emergencies in its hoped
that almost 90 percent of mobile phones
in a defined area could be reached under
the new plans now this system has been
tested in sort of local parts of the
country but on the 23rd of April it's
going to be tested across the country so
that in theory every person on their
mobile phone will receive one of these
messages and you're going to have to
acknowledge that you've received them in
order for the message to stop right so
you've got to make sure you've
acknowledge the notification and just
how wide ranging to think this sort of
thing could become well look it'll be
quite rare that you get one of these
types of messages so you could go for
months if not years and they'll most
likely to be for for situations with
with extreme flooding or like the
wildfires we saw in parts of East London
and Essex last year but there is the
potential that it could be used if there
was something like a terrorist attack
but officials acknowledge that they need
more information about how this
emergency
signaling system could be used in order
for it to be used in such a fast-moving
situation but this scheme has been used
in multiple countries in the US in
Canada so they'll be hoping it could be
used here as well yeah there must be
some concerns there about as a student
sort of sends messages to everyone's
phone well look there's always a
possibility for human error I mean if we
look at 2018 in Hawaii everyone got sent
an alert to their phones that there was
a potential of a missile attack so there
is always the potential and there will
always be uh concerns pumping people
about privacy concerns as well I mean
the cabinet us insists they won't be
collecting data on any members of the
public and crucially you can opt out
this won't be compulsory all right and I
still appreciate that and Oliver darling
from the cabinet offices on later so
maybe so if you'll put a question or two
to him about that thank you for now
all right the Scottish national party
which has enjoyed years of unbroken
electoral success is in a state of chaos
this morning after a series of
resignations and Scandals just weeks
after the first Minister Nicholas
sturgeon announced that she was stepping
down and in the middle of a leadership
election her husband the most powerful
official in the s p has resigned Peter
Murrell had been accused of undermining
the contest to replace Ms sturgeon our
Scotland correspondent Connor Gillies
reports
they were the husband and wife Duo who
dominated the highest ranks of Scottish
politics for decades the pair who led to
the SMP machine the couple who will now
depart sooner than Peter Morrow would
have liked
he's obviously taken responsibility for
the recent issue with membership he had
intended to step down when there was a
new leader but I think he's right to
make that announcement a far from shock
announcement from an embattled SMP chief
executive caught up in controversy
the party's Communications boss resigned
after being instructed by the SMP to
deny this newspaper report a headline
published weeks ago revealing the huge
drop in membership numbers journalism
the party spin doctor was told to
describe as drivel unborn to him it was
fact the true picture concealed
quitting with immediate effect Peter
Murrell said while there was no intent
to mislead I accept this has been the
outcome the membership number should
have been released frankly when the
contest started that's why I think it's
the right thing for Peter to have done
to stood down because as he's in his own
words it was becoming a distraction I
really wanted to get on to talking about
you know the policies what it is I'm
going to bring forward finally the next
first minister of Scotland many within
the SMP have been saying for years that
it simply was not appropriate for the
chief executive of the party to be
married to the leader of the same party
and while this internal leadership
debate has brought about divisions The
crucial part is it's been brought into
the public Arena it's been bitter it's
been ugly and many suggested the longer
Peter Morrow remained in his position
the more damage he was doing to the SMP
and its credibility
this sorry Saga signals a reset for the
SMP it marks the end of the model
sturgeon era in a party left divided and
no closer to Independence as the
leadership battle rages on Conor Gillis
Sky News Glasgow
all right it's just time for a look at
the weather in the sun's just come out
here in Southwest London
or the mild and unsettled theme
continues but Britain's going to be
largely fine today before some more rain
moves in so mostly dry and chilly start
with an early patchy Frost in the north
west but there are one or two showers
around there'll be good spells as
Sunshine through the morning but
increasing Cloud over Island and
Northern Ireland will bring rain to
western parts elsewhere it's going to be
mainly dry but the odd show will affect
Northern Scotland and Central England
Russian State media is reporting that
President Vladimir Putin has visited the
Ukrainian city of Mario pollen what's
believed to be his first visit to
Russian occupied churches of the donbass
since the War Began well this footage is
said to show the Russian presidents
driving around the streets of the city
the port city and was captured by the
Russian forces in the early stages of
the invasion now according to State
media Putin can be seen here visiting a
philharmonic theater the same Hall that
was allegedly used by rush at all
prisoners of War during sham trials that
were held in the city now a short while
ago I spoke to a former special advisor
in Russian Eurasian Affairs Mark Voyager
who told me that Putin's determined show
the rest of the world that he remains in
control
ultimately uh you know as you saw he's
visiting different locations there uh he
wants to show the Russian people that
you know he's taking care of things that
he's personally involved uh this is part
of this uh information Warfare which is
really the centerpiece of Russian hybrid
Warfare but also of Putin's
personalistic uh grip on power I mean
the stability of his regime is the
center of gravity for Putin and
therefore uh he he knows how to play
this information game
well Voyage of that now Donald Trump has
used his social media sites through
social to claim that he's going to be
arrested on Tuesday the former president
is being investigated over a payment
made to the adult film actor Stormy
Daniels to cover up an alleged Affair
well let's bring in the director of the
center of U.S politics it's UCL Dr
Thomas gift doctor give thank you very
much for being with us this morning so
Trump posted this on his own social
media site says there are leaks coming
from the Manhattan DA's office I mean
what do we think of what's going to
happen next week
well Kamali it's important to emphasize
that there's still a lot of information
in this case that's yet to be disclosed
and I think the operative question is
what the actual charge will be if Donald
Trump's Intel is correct because that
will dictate to a large extent how
serious of a disturbance this is to
Trump and what we're in for for these
next several weeks and next several
months and those possibilities really
could run the Spectrum from something
like a relatively minor misdemeanor
involving misrepresenting business
records to something much more serious
like a major contravention of campaign
Finance laws that would be prosecuted as
a felony and technically could carry the
possibility of prison time but either
way if Trump is arrested and uh what
he's saying is correct then this does
spell trouble for him legally there's a
saying that you can indict a ham
sandwich in New York so this case is
unlikely to lose Steam on its own yeah
it's going to continue on I've never
heard that saying about the ham sandwich
let's just go through the sort of the
gamut of the illegal challenges that you
could be facing you say the in
indictment could run from the sort of
misdemeanor to far more serious and it's
all based around this payment for hush
Money Paid that Michael Cohen said a
transform advisor and fixer page two
Stormy Daniels over that alleged Affair
and where that money came from because
Trump eventually reimbursed Michael comb
for it exactly I mean this is a case
that's important to emphasize that's
been going on for quite some time
several years there's a lot of players
involved a lot of accusations that have
been made and it's just really important
I think to emphasize that we don't know
what those charges will be um because it
could as I said before just involve
something relatively minor like
misrepresenting business documents but
if it actually was made in furtherance
of a larger crime dealing with the
campaign that's where the severity uh
becomes much more uh amped up and that's
where things like prison time start to
get uh talked about so it's just really
unclear at the moment would you still be
arrested for the misrepresentation of
documents would it still sort of involve
you know there's been talk of him being
put in handcuffs being fingerprinted
having a mug shot taken but that's what
happened if it was the lower end
well I I think that the charge for
Republicans is that it would if this is
a political Vendetta and selective
prosecution uh and so a lot of this
debate I think really does surround what
the charge is going to be because what
we hear from Defenders of Donald Trump
is yes this is something relatively uh
minor maybe it would be charged as a
misdemeanor but if it were anyone else
besides Donald Trump it would probably
be treated in a way that is much more uh
quiet but because it's Trump because
he's so high profile because there's an
accusation that this district attorney
uh is liberal and maybe pursuing some
type of political Vendetta they're just
trying to make a show about it that we
just don't know
um and so we'll see how that shakes out
and of course we saw the the message
that you posted on Truth socially talks
about fighting and taking back our
country or words to that effect I mean
what impact do you think that will have
because it's very similar language that
was used before the Insurrection on
Capitol Hill back in January the 6th
you're absolutely right Kamali this
could definitely play I think into
Trump's hands politically and Trump
already is using this case to rev up the
base and his comments on true social
calling for protest and to take the
country back but really just a harbinger
of more to come it's all part of Trump's
repertoire that this is a Witch Hunt
it's a political Vendetta it's
overzealous prosecution by radical
district attorney to it's a George Soros
funded hijab this is the kind of
language that we're in for and that
we're already hearing it's very similar
as you suggested uh to what we heard in
the lead up to January 6th it's also
kind of reminiscent of impeachment 1.0
impeachment 2.0 the search of Mar-A-Lago
and of course we know that when it comes
to Trump's most committed base it
doesn't take much to get them to go on
to the offensive so he's going to sort
of use this for all that it's worth
thank you very much for being with us
thank you
now the cost of living crisis is taking
its toll on many including children of
course who want to get involved in the
Arts the sector has been hit by a huge
funding cut in recent years and a
growing number of parents are now being
forced to cut back there are concerns
that the Arts could become a luxury only
available to those who can afford it
actually zahid reports
[Music]
this choir is gearing up for its
showcase performance but behind the
scenes some families are facing
difficult decisions the rising cost of
living means some parents are making
trade-offs While others simply can't
afford it she gets um funding from the
choir to be able to attendance
[Music]
can't do everything
that's why the organizers here are
focusing on being as inclusive as
possible I think without making things
really accessible and free I do fear
that we'll end up with music being a
thing for the for the elite which would
be so sad because I think there's
something in you know who doesn't listen
to music I think everyone's got favorite
type of music new data suggests a
quarter of parents don't have the means
to support their children in the Arts
while a third have cut back on their
children's involvement in art related
activities over the last two decades
culture funding has been cut by 46 in
real terms creative UK says there needs
to be more investment into Arts
education to ensure no child misses out
it's just terribly important that young
people have have access to culture you
know that they have arts in their lives
it's one of the things that we are
uniquely brilliant at and it's something
that enables us to compete globally in
in the international marketplace
um and all of that starts with having a
decent Arts education in schools in
response the spokesperson said the
government is investing heavily in the
Arts and has committed to providing 446
million per year to Arts organizations
through the Arts Council England with
almost 80 percent of these delivering
activities specifically for children and
young people
for now it's hope the situation doesn't
get any worse the last thing the
organizers here want to see is more
families being priced out Aisha zahid
Sky News
all right let's take a look at what the
weather is going to store for us for the
next couple of days
well it's going to be mild and unsettled
but it's gonna be largely fine for most
of us today before more rain moves in
I'm mostly dry in chilly start with an
early patchy Frost in the Northwest but
there are a couple of showers around two
there'll be some good Spells Of Sunshine
through the morning but increasing cloud
of Island and Northern Ireland will
bring rain to western parts it's going
to be dry with the odd shower will
affect Northern Scotland and Central
England hello welcome back let's take
another look at uh what's making news in
some of the morning's newspapers here
with me to look through them are the
political editor the Sunday Mirror Nigel
Nelson and the journalist and
broadcaster Benicia mamata Nigel bitisha
good to have you back with us again all
right it says crack on and go through
some of the front pages and Nigel will
start with you your Sunday Mirror and
the front page dag Gary lineker and
Britain should be proud of linica take
us through the reporting on this
yeah yeah I mean Gary lineke is still uh
up there in the headlines uh as uh uh
we're now days aft after the controversy
uh well this is an interview with a law
student who was a human rights activist
in Pakistan and uh Gary lineker took him
in for 20 days
um and he's got nothing but praise for
for lineker uh he also reveals that it
that uh going because a fantastic cook
apparently who makes mind-blowing meals
as he describes it I I think that the
original tweet uh really did go too far
but then the BBC made such a huge mess
of their response to it what is actually
good news is that Gary line Cruz back on
TV doing what he does best which is
commentating on Sports uh and now it's
business as usual and let's hope he
stays that way yeah quick thought from
you and uh you can comment if you like
on garlic and being an excellent cook
uh he can cook for me anytime he likes
I'm a very happy professional eater I
completely agree with that analysis I
think that this has been a storm in a
teacup and it's also indicative of the
way that traditional media Outlets
really have to get on board with the
fact that their presenters particularly
much love veteran presents they know
themselves extremely well they have
strong personalities do have their own
private social media accounts and on
those accounts they may well say
something about whatever's happening in
the news headlines of the day I don't
think that what linick has said was very
extreme in One Direction or another so
these things do happen and the big media
outlets need to get on board with that
yeah let's keep moving through some of
the stories this morning buddition will
stick with you uh sorry we were just
covering a short while ago Donald Trump
claiming he's going to be arrested come
Tuesday it's been covered in a number of
the newspapers and this is the coverage
that we've got here in the Sunday
Telegram tell us about this
yes this follows on from that excellent
interview you just did with the analyst
talking about Trump who claims he's
about to be arrested there is no proof
that he is indeed about to be arrested
One unconfirmed Source says that there
is in fact a rumor that Alvin Bragg the
district attorney will be meeting with
law enforcement on Tuesday so something
is happening on Tuesday and of course
the DA's office Hollywood movie style is
investigating the US twice impeached
president over claims that he had made
payments to Stormy Daniels but of course
people are commenting particularly
Republican partisan fans of trump
they're saying well you know frankly
presidents have always done this this is
what politicized attempt at trying to
get this guy into prison but it's really
about the attack on the capital on the
6th of January in 2021 I don't think
that analysis is wrong I think the DA's
office do it indeed want to get Trump
for something and it is true that
they're investigating him and they're
working with the police and law
enforcement so something is happening
yeah there are other events going on as
well with his tax Affairs too I want to
get you to dwell on that knowledge let's
keep moving on and go to a another story
that's making headlines this morning and
this is one that's been running all week
um but some commentary about it in the
times that you've picked out Nigel and
this is the situation in France we've
seen protests so died down a little bit
past a couple of days but after Manuel
macron falls through uh change the
pension policy people took to the
streets which is not unusual in France
but uh you might have some issues coming
in the next few weeks
trying to raise the pension age from 62
to 64.
um and he wants to do this by pushing it
through Parliament without a vote
because of course he doesn't have a
majority there which may uh end up with
a no confidence vote in him
um it does have a bit extraordinary the
French are quite so upset about this I
mean given that in the UK the pension
age is going up to 68 though the the
French have got it rather good on the
basis of it only being 64. and of course
with the with one of the biggest
problems facing his Globe years and age
is aging population
it's inevitable that the pension age is
going to go up people are fitter for
longer and therefore they can work
longer yeah absolutely right butisha a
quick thought from you on there before
we move on to the next story
yes I think the controversy here is that
this move to go forward without a
parliamentary vote doesn't have the
support of the people or indeed of
macron's political colleagues so it's
seen as part of his jupiterian style of
leadership and his argument is of course
exactly as we just said about the rising
life expectancy but also the fact that
paying out pensions is adding to
France's very high national debt and yet
it's all happening at a time of protest
so next week and in the coming weeks
you're going to see strikes across train
drivers oil rig workers other public and
Civil Service workers at Civil Society
workers there's a sense that there's a
great remoteness between the leadership
and the travails of ordinary people so
this attempt to force through something
without a voter seeing as being part of
that that macro is out of touch yeah a
British let's stick with you then
because a couple more stories to get
through I want to get to this one in the
sun
um 25 000 teachers attacked by kids
that's the headline there but he should
give us some of the details let's
remember that there have been teachers
strikes this week there are they are in
talks of the government at the moment
but uh some of the concerns from
teachers not just about pays the
conditions they have to work in and I
guess this headline here isn't kind of
indicative of what might be going on in
some schools
yes that's exactly it so this article
isn't really about student and pupil
Behavior it's about the level of
compensation paid out to teachers not
just through aggression or poor
discipline in the classroom but also
through health and safety through having
to work in buildings which have an
asbestos problem through injury through
accident it all points to the same few
things Decades of under investment A
system that isn't joined up that isn't
hanging together poor confidence in the
abilities of teachers and a lack of
support for teachers in doing what they
were called to do by their vocation
which is to teach and enrich young
people and of course it ties in with
lots of worries and headlines at the
moment about student Behavior aggression
machismo in the classroom what are we
teaching young people the influence of
social media that's part of it but it's
also really about the sense of loss of
confidence loss of a sense of support
that teachers themselves have I think
that's the real Scandal here that this
is one of the noblest professions and
yet it's not being adequately supported
or respected but apparently by anyone
now Nigel that will be a concern when
it's not being respected clearly by
anyone who's producer points out I've
got a long like just a quick thought
from you if you can
yeah I would do that that um as barisha
says it's really about compensation this
story so it doesn't tell us what is
going on in schools
um but it sounds like we've got 25 000
attacks on on teachers ofsted needs to
get involved and sort out what is that
happening and you see in these
particular schools